hey guys welcome back the new rock stars
I'm Sam basher 2017 is coming to a close
and we've had quite a stellar superhero
and comic book year guys we've had
Wonder Woman Logan Thor Ragnarok I'll
stop there because we're not supposed to
look at the past dear children we have
to look to the future
almost every studio out there almost
every single one is gearing up to
release a slew of comic book movies in
2018 thank the Lord you guys are
probably thinking to yourself Sam
I already know all of them of course I
do have a little advent calendar for the
release of each of those movies first
off that's awesome
I want one send it to me second trust me
there are some of these movies that
honest to god I absolutely forgot we're
coming out next year or I thought they
were just in talks I didn't know they
were being made so get out of your
calendars kids and start marking down
every comic book movie coming out in
2018 starting with the movie I'm
currently most excited for Black Panther
mark off February 16th boys and girls
for the first solo outing for the king
of Wakanda on the big screen so cool
quick synopsis for you after the events
of Marvel's captain America Civil War
king T'Challa returns home to the
reclusive technologically advanced
African nation of Wakanda to serve as
his country's new leader
however T'Challa soon finds that he's
challenged for the throne from fractions
within his own country when two foes
conspire to destroy Wakanda the hero
known as Black Panther must team up with
CIA agent everett k ross and members of
the Durham mulashi Wakanda special
forces to prevent makanda from being
dragged into a world war as we're
getting Michael B Jordan as the main
antagonist kill monger teaming up with
any circuses Klaw not to mention the
Lapita and young goes and be starring in
this force would occur
Daniel Kalia Martin Freeman freaked me
this cast is magical let's keep scooting
down the tower to April 13th for the
release of the next x-men film the genre
blending New Mutants you guys missed the
trailer we'll be getting a new take on
the x-men universe one that's dipping
its toe into the horror genre bummer
that this one's not coming out during a
Halloween but still intrigue quickie
synopsis 5 jung eum's
just discovering their abilities while
held in a secret facility
against their well fight to escape their
past sins and save themselves very
interesting this will also be the debut
of magic Hannibal Wolfsbane Mirage and
they return once again of sunspot or a
version of him fans of stranger things
Game of Thrones and split should be
excited since this will be starring
Charlie Heaton Anya Taylor joy and
Maisie Williams their own teaming up
just sold meat on the movie thanks Sam
welcome Sam next oh that's right
may 4th marca calendars is a
we'll be coming out I don't know if you
guys are gonna be interested it's gonna
have one of the guys from Dancing with
the Stars in it uh he's a villain from
the shaggy-dog remake and the girl from
home on three sound interesting to you
be honest was really fun to look up all
those weird roles cuz I'm talking about
Chris Hemsworth Robert Downey jr. and
scar Joe because we're finally getting
it and Justin fit anymore can you
believe it I'm so excited if you guys
want to know more about this film I
recommend checking out our episodes on
need to know where we pitch what we
think this movie's going to be exactly
how it's gonna play out it has been
described as having elements of a heist
movie with Thanos hunting down the
Infinity stones to assemble the Infinity
Gauntlet while Earth's Mightiest Heroes
band together to stop him plus the
Guardians a galaxy because they're great
but is this more exciting than the
return of the Merc with a mouth yes it
is because I'm waiting a long time for
this but still Deadpool 2 is writing
right behind
infinity war hitting theaters June 1st
2018 this movie has one of the most
intriguing cast of people I'd like to
watch on the big screen plus characters
I've been dying to see I'm talking about
a cast that includes Josh Brolin sassy
beets Julianne Denison from hunt for the
world of people it's amazing movie
directed by Taika Waititi
but also we're finally getting cable in
a movie I personally love to look at
cable in this movie I think he looks
awesome think he looks realistic I love
it but also we're getting a freaking
Domino live-action Domino if Deadpool
ain't so much your thing no worries
because one month after that you're
getting another Marvel movie MCU to be
exact ant-man and the wasp hits theaters
July 6 oh my goodness so many movies
it's barely half a year in this movie
while Scott Lang balances being both a
superhero and a father hope Van Dyne and
dr. Hank Pym present an urgent new
mission that finds ant-man fighting
alongside the wasps who uncover secrets
from their past mmm you better believe
that's a little hint about the fate of
Janet Van Dyne Hanks wife and hopes
mother the original wasp she's gonna be
here can't wait to see Michelle
Pfeiffer's version of Janet joined the
MCU and Laurence Fishburne joining as
Goliath a lesser-known character but
still awesome I'm an excited boy but
hang on to your boats kids because
July's got another little gift via DC
and Warner Brothers are bringing the
Teen Titans to the big screen on July
27th now I don't sound that excited
because this isn't a feature film for
the teen titans this is actually a
feature film for the Teen Titans go
cartoons
I'm not the biggest fan of that show
actually a bigger fan of the original
series which is a popular opinion online
but that doesn't mean this movie is bad
or is going to be bad or anything like
that I'm just not the most excited about
it there's no plot details as of right
now but hey it could be fun I'll take my
nephew
to go see it they'll love it and hey
this might be the only time we'll see
the Titans on the big screen I'd be
bummed out if that statement was true
but uh try stay optimistic and we've got
a little bit of breathing room until
Halloween time that's when we have an
extra spooky comic book movie coming out
very excited kicking off Halloween with
venom coming out October 5th what we've
been told so far about these movies is
that there are spider-man spin-offs
they're loosely connected to one another
and they're separate from the MCU why no
frickin clue I'll be honest not a clue
but they'll be there but at the very
least we know this venom movie is going
to have a horror take and will be
directed by a Ruben Fleischer from the
zombie land which is an amazing movie
makes me very happy
the infamous Eddie Brock we play it by
not Topher Grace's sadly but actually
Tom Hardy he will be joined by at Riz
Ahmed Michelle Williams and Jenny slight
pretty good cast and what we've been
told so far is that venom will be going
up against his weird offspring carnage
very excited about that and it will be
based off of the lethal protector
storyline which is a fan favorite are
you guys excited about this one does it
feel weird to you let me know down below
speaking of non MCU movies don't be
upset if you were missing a third x-men
movie next year because there's gonna be
one yep I totally forgot about x-men the
Dark Phoenix coming out in 2018 or at
all but it's coming I'm excited I'm just
caught by surprise but yay holy crap
it's got everybody in it apparently this
is not just a spin-off that the x-men
films we're trying to do this is an
actual installment in the x-men
franchise you've got the young
Nightcrawler from apocalypse you got
beasts coming back nicholas hoult you
got cyclops mystique Professor X
everybody as well as Jessica Chastain
who will be the antagonist I'm just not
sure who yet coming out November 2nd
make sure you market calendars
only two more left guys Sony actually
has a very special animated movie coming
out starring one of my favorite spider
people Miles Morales woman excited about
this one it was not so a while ago that
there were plans for an animated
spider-man movie coming out for December
14th and I've been pumped ever since I
actually just powered through all of
Miles Morales
ultimate run in the comics and I
realized why everybody loves him he's
fantastic he's amazing fun fact the
script was penned by one half of Phil
Lord and Chris Miller at the phil lord
have specifically also should make more
from dope and the get down on netflix
will be voicing Miles Morales and Liev
Schreiber will be voicing the antagonist
but no news yet as to who he will be
playing who do you want miles to go up
against in his film debut let me know
down below and finally to cap off the
year of 2018 let's give it up to Aquaman
in his first solo film December 21st
guys barely making it in there sorry
Jason Momoa and
Patrick Wilson Nicole Kidman Willem
Dafoe and the main man himself
Dolph Lundgren hail yet the official
synopsis hasn't been released yet but
it's definitely leaning towards part
they're curious origins his family
learning about Atlantis and him going up
against Black Manta who we played by
yaya abdullah martina ii and ocean
master played by patrick wilson really
wished we saw the footage from comic-con
I wish the DC would release that but
we'll just have to wait like five months
or something still optimistic and really
quick guys here are two honorable
mentions that are typically not comic
books but they still count I need to
talk about him mark your calendars for
June 15th because we're finally getting
a sequel to The Incredibles no synopsis
yet but who isn't excited for this movie
am i right and finally the film
adaptation of the popular manga Alita
battle angel is finally hitting theaters
finally hopefully maybe originally James
Cameron was set to direct and write the
adaptations but now Robert Rodriguez is
looking to be the director so very cool
I still enjoyed Rodriguez the style of
the machete movies starring Rosa Salazar
Moe Herschel Ali Christoph Waltz Eliza
Gonzales Michelle Rodriguez Jennifer
Connelly the list goes on and on this is
an incredible cast that's all I'll say
for right now in case you guys aren't
familiar with the property and want to
be surprised when you go sleep in
theaters but that's it for me which
movie are you guys most excited for in
2018 all of them me too let me know if
they happen to miss any of these comic
book movies in the comments down below
or on twitter at Sam bash or make sure
you like this video share it with your
friends and subscribe the new rock stars
for more content
again I'm Sam basher and I'll see you
next time